يوم ساخن في التصعيد الاسرائيلي ضد قطاع
غزه مع وصول عدد شهداء الى 29 ومقتل
اسرائيليا بقصف صواريخ المقاومه بدا هذا
اليوم بغاره اسرائيليه استهدفت شقه سكنيه
في خان يونس وادت الى استشهاد ثلاثه
فلسطينيين بينهم علي غالي عضو المجلس
العسكري لسرايا القدس مسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه فيها وبعد ساعات اغتالت اسرائيل
ايضا احمد ابو دقه نائب غالي في مسؤوليه
الوحدات الصاروخيه لسرايا القدس قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان رئيس هيئه الاركان ورئيس
جهاز الشبك الشرفاه على اغتيال قائد
الوحدات الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس ساعه
قليله بعد اغتيال غالي حتى تحولت مستوطنات
غلاف غزه الى اهداف صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والتي انطلقت بكثافه من قطاع
غزه التحول النوعي في صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اليوم كان استهداف مدينه
روحفوت جنوبيه تل ابيب ادى ذلك لمقتل
اسرائيلي واصابه اخرين بعد ان اصاب صاروخ
منزلا بشكل مباشر هناك وتعطلت الدراسه في
المدينه ومحيطها اهميه ريخوفات انها لا
تبعد الا بضعه كيلومترات فقط عن مطار بن
غوريون في مدينه ليد جنوبي تل ابيب وقبل
ان تنتهي ساعه الليل قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه قصف 191 هدفا تابعا للجهاد الاسلامي
في قطاع غزه مقابل اطلاق اكثر من 800
صاروخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه الاهداف
الاسرائيليه في محيط القطاع وفي العمق
الاسرائيلي